un bacio un bacio ancora e per via verso
l'ignoto
tutto questo è tanto shaun huyghen bp
ricorda spia il tuo amore ma ascolta il
tuo cuore
ciao sono valeria marini e lei è sexy
star
ho ripreso la mia love story con patrick
e voglio capire se questo rapporto è
destinato a riprendere il volo oppure no
valeria ha un carattere difficile non è
facile starle dietro
ha tanti lati positivi altri che vi
lasciano un po perplesso ma sono sicuro
che questo programma mi aiuterà a capire
se questa storia ha un futuro
oppure chissà vorrei che tirasse fuori
il suo carattere perché c'è la a me
piacciono le tentazioni
ciao sono stefano ho 46 anni e mi devo
sopportare questa bambolina
mi chiamo nicoletta larini ho 24 anni e
io quei ragazzi della mia età non mi ci
trovo assolutamente le piace il vecchio
via
no mi piacciono le persone mature di
testa stefano ea me quando mi chiamavi
in vetta mi fa salire i meriti
cioè mi fa in maniera male proprio
quando mi sono fidanzato con nicoletta
non la sentivo questa differenza della
nell'ultimo periodo
mi ritrovo a fare di un genitore che il
compagno via
vorrei capire se la differenza di età
tra me e stefano possa in qualche modo
condizionare il futuro del nostro sport
le nostre coppie non sono ancora
sbarcate ma tra una di loro è già
scoppiato un brutto litigio dopo cinque
mesi che ci stiamo conoscendo dopo tutto
quello che è successo dopo i litigi ttg
tuoi soffio perché non sai cos'è il
rispetto è solo colpa tua
perché vado a ballare alla sera con la
mia amica perché non ti comporti da uomo
impegnato soffio
perché ti stai creando un alibi tu vuoi
venire a vivere con me cosa hai bisogno
di a casa all'ora soffio ma valeva
valeria matata e valeria ei arrivo nel
frattempo preso una susina ma dove sono
gli altri sono già andati via
baghdad
che buona io adoro le susine il frutto
della passione
conosciamo insieme i piantatori valeria
quale ti piace di più di questi
tentatori esteticamente è allora
innanzitutto volevo farvi i complimenti
perché la vostra scelta è stata pazzesca
veramente stellare che bello quel
tatuaggio riesce ai coloni ivan vale
mattina blas espagnol perché è spagnola
io a bromley viene la spagnola tve ha
det on the air show sono di un piccolo
paese di andalusia
però adesso vivono vite va bene io che
ero hablar e spagnola ap rovesciarlo e
allora conosciamo meglio i nostri
tentatori ciao sono i one e ho 26 anni e
vivo a madrid da sole davvero e spagnolo
sono noi caliente è molto passionale
una cosa che mi piace tantissimo fare e
ballare la facciata bravo allora poi
vogliamo insieme
mettiamoli colotto 25 anni uno dei miei
sogni è quello di avere una famiglia
unita e solida
sembra una banalità però quando
nell'infanzia non hai avuto la fortuna
di poterla avere
è una cosa che cerchi ragazzi e ragazze
è arrivato il momento di salutarvi sai a
cosa mi serviranno tutti questi giorni
per capire se posso perdonare tutte le
accuse che mi hai fatto tutte le brutte
parole che hai detto soprattutto le
brutte parole che hai detto stessa il
patetico
poi solo la vittima facevi prima dirmelo
prima non entravamo neanche
il nostro viaggio nei sentimenti inizia
ora
benvenuti al primo falò di tentation
island vip
iniziamo con te patrick mi dispiace ma
ho diciotto video per te
chi si conoscerà passerà a lo capisci le
spagnole né la norma nera da prendere
una lingua e tenere un ovvio quando tu
me parla in italiano
ami me piace da morire e allora io ti
parla in italiano
tu però a plan in spagna al 28 posso
fare lezione bee spagnolo ripetuto
quello che vuoi e il sema ferrata cosa
vuol dire lasciamo tornata facciamo e
l'amore è sempre però prescritto tue nei
tatuaggi o qua sul culo baci stellare
d'elsa stellar e ti fa prendere il volo
io vedo una persona che non ha voglia
dice di voler capire determinate cose ma
facendo così non ne sta capendo mista
solo allontanando a me fa male fa male
vederla così io non è la valeria che
conosco passiamo a theo sola mi dispiace
ma anche per te a 15 video
1 2 3 e 4 più sensuale ti devi poter
appoggiare a me buzzati così battigia e
poi è molto sensuale abbracciati
abbracciati a me
bravo bravo ma questo è pazzo
questa è la persona più schifosa del
mondo gli è stato chiesto sei innamorato
di me ha detto no però poi vuole venire
a vivere a casa mia
vi rendete conto 47 anni che schifo
nicoletta o un video per te
[Musica]
viviamo
no
ma vabbè simo si leva sulle montagne in
mare sta critiche nudo kilowatt e
apprendere lo distruggo altro che
capelli stefano ma perchè fai questo
ma non sente e non sei te perchè fai
questo
ma ci pensi a me no si muoiono lo
riconosco un colpo al cuore perché sa
come sono
me l'aveva promesso sono stato a mare in
questi giorni adesso starò peggio
io non so che dire simo non lo riconosco
perché mi fa questo a me manca
tantissimo ma proprio tanto ma perché fa
questo se voi non lo riconosco non lo
riconosco più
il nostro viaggio nei sentimenti è
appena iniziato ma le nostre coppie sono
già state messe a dura prova si
lasceranno fermeranno a casa insieme
troveranno un altro amore
lo scopriremo nella prossima puntata a
tutto il personale
se questa prima puntata di the passion
island it vi è piaciuta ricordatevi di
iscrivervi nel mio canale e inseguirmi
su tutti gli altri social in star
facebook e tic toc spia il tuo amore ma
ascolta il tuo cuore
baci stellari a d'oro
[Musica]
beh spia il tuo cuore
[Applauso]